so let's get some reaction to this now
joining me is Dave Penman who's General
Secretary of the civil servants Union
the FDA a very good morning to you so is
this appointment do you think an
appropriate one
well akuba the body that looks at
outside deployments will obviously have
to make a decision but certainly as Noah
former civil servant she's resigned
that's the right thing to do if you're
going to take up an appointment that
requires the coma process to to approve
it but I mean uh it was only 18 months
ago everyone was loading the Integrity
in impartiality
um of sugary that hasn't changed in any
way she is more than capable of doing a
big job for labor in terms of preparing
for government and separating out that
from her former room as a civil servant
so I think some of the claims about
partygate report Etc to be honest are
just extraordinary
well yes and as you say it's Boris
Johnson and supporters of Boris Johnson
who are saying that this implies
impartiality they're saying that she's a
top civil servant who ruled on partygate
obviously damning for the for the prime
minister at the time Boris Johnson now
taking up a political job and they would
say that it implies that Sue gray was
sympathetic to labor while making her
findings
but civil servants are impartial uh
every day you know many civil servants
and labor supports many civil servants
are concept of supporters you don't
become as self-observant unless you're
prepared to put that
um to this age when you do your job and
sugary was asked by the prime minister
to conduct this investigation she didn't
seek it out it wasn't a left-wing plot
and she was asked if Samuel case had to
accuse himself and what she did which is
what a civil servants do is go after the
evidence so she produced a report which
was welcomed at the time including by
the Prime Minister those that are
criticized in the party report I'm not
saying there's anything wrong with that
they are just trying to smear it on the
basis of what happened a year later in
relation to shows and potential
appointment with the labor party so it's
just extraordinary that they're trying
to use that and also what we're talking
about here is someone who has given the
life to Public Service you know she had
a fearful reputation for her Integrity
uh she's done some of the most difficult
jobs in government and like it's really
disappointing to see ministers now try
to trash that simply because she's
decided to take a very different job
later on in her career
and then in the course of that job
she'll also have seen very sensitive uh
details about policy making but also
personal details when ruling on matters
of Ethics we're told the prime minister
is concerned that she could use this
privileged information to benefit the
labor party is that a worry
well every 707 and Minister gets to see
things that are are private for the
government and they all face a
responsibility when they leave
government deal of saying the official
Secrets act they know that they have to
if you're going to work in government
and work somewhere else you have to find
a way of separating that out there are
many occasions where there are ministers
who have dealt with businesses that they
then go on to to to work for they have
to find a way of saying well actually I
will not do this I will not be involved
in that those are the sorts of things
that Koba look at and say okay then
there is a potential conflict here how
can we how can we facilitate someone
with a job outside of the Civil Service
or I would say the government in the
case of a minister but also protect the
public interest but the idea that sugary
would somehow
um is taking this job to divulge the
secrets of the conservative party or
government it's obviously just nonsense
and most ministers understand and know
that she has bound with the restrictions
of all civil servants I've known by but
what she did during her day she no
longer works for civil service those
restrictions continue to apply where
whoever she works for whether it's a
labor party or whether it was someone
else
this comes at a time though when the
civil servants has been criticized by
some as being anti-government this
doesn't help does it
well those people are criticized in the
Civil Service uh has been
anti-government without any evidence
whatsoever so of course they're going to
LEAP on at something like this but there
is nothing to suggest there's any
substance to that if you're a civil
servant if you've done your career on
the Civil Service and and you're a labor
supporter most of your career you've
bought for a conservative government
that's the nature of the job you'll have
dealt with the policies whether you
agree with him or not civil servants
absolutely understand this is not a
surprise to some observance that's what
they sign up for when they come and work
in the Civil Service they'll be
conservative voting civil service so how
do you want from labor that's just the
nature of the job
however given her access to privileged
information do you accept there should
be a cooling off period between her
leaving the Civil Service and going to
work for the labor party
well as a parent secretary she's got an
automatic free month killing off period
in any event I mean this is an unusual
Point there's no point getting about
that someone doesn't tend to take this
sort of job with the opposition
seamlessly civil servants there are many
civil servants working uh for government
you're still working for the
conservative party there's usually a
longer period of time so a cobra will
need to look at that and say is there
any there needs to be extension Beyond
three months around that that's the sort
of thing that they will be considering
or potential restrictions on on what she
can work on but she's already got three
months that's compulsory on permanent
secretaries to create a separation
between what they've done in the Civil
Service and uh where they're going to
work
and the Prime Minister makes the
ultimate decision doesn't he isn't that
right do you think he could block this
I mean ultimately
um uh there are some questions I'm not
I'm not an expert on the powers of
October the Prime Minister on these I
think it would um I think it would be
channelish to be honest of the Prime
Minister that it would look like a a
very kind of vindictive act if you
sought to block it they will clearly be
concerns you're understandable concerns
about someone who's at the heart of
government going to work for the
opposition and there will be a
reasonable way of dealing with that no
one knows that more than so because she
would probably be the sort of person
who'd be advising a prime minister if
someone else was doing this while she
was in government and she will
understand that and want to work with
the cover and make those uh assurances
as well but the idea that the Prime
Minister I think would kind of
permanently block it or create such a
length for a period of time I think
we'll be completely unjustified and
would look like I think Petty and
vindictive
okay well Dave Penman we appreciate your
time this morning thanks for your
thoughts thank you